holy smokes I'm going into war the
Vietnam War resulted in more than 1.3
million deaths and it's one of the most
divisive painful and poorly understood
episodes in American history
documentarians Ken Burns and Lynn Novick
have spent the past decade making a film
that aims to exhume the Wars buried
history their 10 part series which
premieres on PBS next week is a
comprehensive look at the secrecy
disinformation and spin surrounding
Vietnam I don't think it's worth
fighting I don't think we can get out
and the lasting impact of the war on two
nations the 18 hour film combines
never-before-seen historical footage
with testimonies from nearly 80
witnesses including soldiers on both
sides of the conflict leaders of the
protest movement and civilians from
North and South Vietnam
I spoke with burns and Novick about why
they believe examining what happened in
Vietnam is essential to understanding
American life today so this is an
exhaustive comprehensive look at
America's involvement in the Vietnam War
which you note began in secrecy and
ended in failure what prompted the
project for you and why should we be
talking about Vietnam now I think it's
time to talk about it it's some
repressed memory for many of us and and
deliberately avoided subject for perhaps
the rest of us Lynn and I were finishing
a film on the second world war called
simply the war and before it was done in
2006 we already knew sort of intuitively
that we would have to jump into Vietnam
we think it's the most important event
in American history in the second half
of the 20th century and if we want to
know a little bit about the sort of
political divisions and the lack of
civil discourse that beset us and the
devilís today we think that a lot of the
seeds of that were planted in Vietnam
and if you could unpack literally unpack
the sort of fraudulence of the
conventional wisdom and repack it
benefiting from the testimony of people
who went lived through it and the recent
scholarship that's taken place and also
to triangulate with the South Vietnamese
and North Vietnamese perspectives which
are almost always left behind
that you have an opportunity to perhaps
understand it better and maybe pull out
some of these fuel rods of discourse and
sort of get back to sort of what we
often do very well early on and I think
it's in the first episode you you like
it or the I can't remember if it's one
of the commenters or the or the
narration but our narration would never
do that strictly strictly neutral it is
a talking hand well okay so somebody
said likens the experience of Vietnam to
living with an alcoholic father how does
that speak to this idea of a repressed
memory or you know a kind of ghost
that's hovering everywhere but can never
be fully acknowledged when you're
talking about a family live with an
alcoholic there's a lot of shame and not
knowing what to say and just avoiding it
and pretending it's not happening I
think that those are very common to just
work that metaphor that he uses Karl
Marlantes who's a marine and that was
his personal experience of coming home
and finding that no one talked about the
war and you just shut that door and just
move on if you really try to unpack that
like Ken and I have done I think it's an
enormous trauma for our country that we
just have never actually been able to
talk about because it is so painful and
we were curious to find out why and then
just put the pieces back together as Ken
just said but you know the the the idea
that you can ignore something and hope
it will go away and that we all know
that doesn't work too well and so the
result of that is that we're still kind
of arguing in a way we sort of fought
the Vietnam War many years ago but we're
still fighting the way we remember it so
talk about that because is it you know
and the various sequences or episodes
talked about particularly Lyndon Johnson
you know who opened up what became known
as the credibility gap it was clearly
saying one thing privately another thing
publicly to a point where he couldn't
even run for president in 68 is that
what you're talking about when you're
saying I mean this is a place where
Vietnam kind of is the story it's one of
the places because of course that's on
one political and policy level there's
another military one there's another
intimate one that may involve protesters
or gold star families or the soldiers
themselves who are walking on eggshells
but the film very clearly says that
from Harry Truman and Dwight Eisenhower
and John F Kennedy and particularly
Lyndon Johnson and Richard Nixon and to
a lesser extent Gerald Ford
nobody was straight with the American
people nobody that that credibility gap
began with Truman when so much stuff was
done in secret continued with Eisenhower
continued with Kennedy escalated
significantly with Kennedy and even more
so exponentially so with Johnson and
then you had in Richard Nixon somebody
who came in with his national security
adviser absolutely understanding the
real politique as they would say of it
we need to end this war and fast and
find themselves using some of the same
set of rationales the same sort of
justifications and the same sort of
dissembling that the other presidents
have used to sort of kick the can down
the street and not deal with Vietnam
which gets a lot of Americans and even
more Vietnamese killed so this is an
ongoing if you want to about Rolling
Thunder there's a kind of rolling
dissembling is the big bombing campaign
that Lyndon Johnson initiated to sort of
what they thought would bring the north
to their knees that bring them to the
bargaining table saying what do you need
in the north making its own horrific
calculus and not consulting with its own
people are going to decide that they
will not as I said count the cost and
that means that when we looked at the
body counts on the on the news it was
always 10 to 1 or even sometimes in 20
to 1 since Tuesday 179 enemy have been
killed others are trapped in a cave
complex us losses so far four Americans
dead 19 wounded and they said that we to
absorb it in a democracy or something
similar to that it became very clear
that there's just so many years where
you can accept even that one before you
say no mas that I think is one of the
really fascinating elements of the
series is the as you were saying both
South Vietnamese and North Vietnamese as
well as the account perspectives but it
was that weird mirror of you know it's
Robert McNamara the Secretary of Defense
is talking about the body can you know
how can we lose we're killing them ten
to one but it was the exact opposite on
the North Vietnamese side and there's a
hubris there in an era gay
Oh completely and this is what we have
to say is that none of these governments
in saigon ha noi washington were frank
with their people obviously in a
repressive communist regime you're going
to expect the utter control of media
which happened oh you only talk about
victories you never mention a single
defeat and and that's important but
you're not gonna ever know what happened
to your son and why he's not back and
you know the justification for the war
the reason why are we there
kept shifting for americans and for our
leaders sort of explaining first it was
to contain communism and it became to
preserve our reputation and to help
south vietnam and you know to contain
China or to restrict China's expansion
but the ground kept shifting and we
didn't see any real benchmark that we
actually were making progress that was
always the real huge challenge that's
why McNamara was they were so obsessed
with the numbers you have kind of the
same where I can't remember if it's on
Meet the Press or face a nation where
general Westmoreland is well I can give
you a bunch of statistics on how we're
winning and it's all like we're stopping
this many flights I'm shooting those
bullets but there was no real indicator
right exactly what they they couldn't
figure that out I mean one of our
scholars we had an incredible panel of
advisers and one of them dragged at us
great historians you've heard a whole
book about how it was impossible to
measure victory and they tried and tried
and tried neglected so much data they
were drowning in data but they weren't
measuring the thing that really mattered
the feelings of the Vietnamese people
and ultimately they didn't really fully
understand how what the war how our
conduct of the war and our inability to
actually have a coherent reason for
being there that resonated with the
American people over the course of it
you know that's part of the calculus and
they couldn't find a way to measure that
and part of the tragedy is that many
people in government at high policy
levels understood exactly and and and
did not reflect it so you can hear in
the tapes the anguish of LBJ or the
anguish of Richard Nixon and then they
both go out that later that day or the
next day and say the exact opposite of
what's going on and what we know as the
Pentagon Papers is in fact Robert
McNamara's you know a study that he
commissioned that was going to sort of I
think satisfy all these nagging
that he had about the war and it shows
that from Truman on everybody understood
that this was a resilient insurgency
that that the really the notion of a
proxy war or the containment of
communism wasn't the quite the right fit
for what was happening in Vietnam so
it's it's part of one of the mistakes
that the the generals and the the
presidents or the politicians made as
they mistook a civil war for a cold war
it's it I think that's one way to say it
but you know as we found out it was
really impossible to sort of say with
certainty about anything so what we've
done is try to present all the cases and
as many perspectives as we can and just
say look at the mess I mean that's the
element of tragedy they're always free
electrons and our own philosophies and
ideologies would attempt to tie
everything up in a neat bow that's
certainly the great tragic flaw of
Marxism was that it thought I could
explain everything in a simple dialectic
and what we know is that human nature
and human experience and will always
sabotage that so at what point did
America did it the American kind of
political class know that this was not
going to be a winnable war I think one
of the really interesting moments that
we show in the film is there's hearings
on Capitol Hill of the Fulbright foreign
the Foreign Service Committee chaired by
J William Fulbright and the Senate has
hearings about the war in 1966 and some
very respected foreign policy experts
including George Kennan come forward and
say containments not relevant here and
you know if we were not already in
Vietnam I see no reason why we should
get involved in Vietnam and I have a
fear that our thinking about this whole
problem is still affected by some sort
of illusions about invincibility on our
part that there is no problem a feeling
that there is no problem in the world
which we if we wanted to devote enough
of our resources to it could not solve I
just believe in this most profoundly and
he's the father of container thank you
yes it's it's a gradual dawning there's
information in many places that the Wars
not going well CIA reports army reports
intelligence analysis and I think our
leaders have access to
that but they you know they don't see a
way out nonetheless with the Tet
Offensive it became okay to say out loud
inside the White House inside the
Pentagon and be sort of you know have a
credible voice you know maybe we should
you know maybe this isn't going to work
out and before that if there was no sort
of way to really say that publicly and
each of the presidential candidates are
the major ones George Wallace Nixon and
Hubert Humphrey all campaigned in 68
saying they wanted to Swift an honorable
peace that's created nob so it was great
kind of bizarre that you you know what
campaign each of them is saying the same
thing you also I think one other factor
we're bringing it would be the press you
know which had gone there in classic
American fashion almost jingoistic Lee
in support of this effort to contain
communism and help the people of South
Vietnam you know free themselves from
the this horrific you know threat and
and then began to say that that the
press release is coming out of Saigon or
Washington were not what they were
witnessing or hearing from the field
commanders and so you had almost the at
the very beginning these very respected
journalists like David Halberstam and
and Neil Sheehan and Malcolm Brown all
beginning to say hey what's going on
here so you do have everybody making
decisions for domestic political
consideration meaning will I get elected
and that's Truman who is being blamed
for losing China it's it's JFK who has
come in and heritage the disastrous Bay
of Pigs he's been humiliated by
Khrushchev and in in Vienna he can't
stop the the Soviets from building the
Berlin wall and he's decided not to
intervene in an insurgency and Laos that
President Eisenhower ex-president
Eisenhower's pushing him to do and so he
feels he has to draw the line or not be
reelected as he admits and of course we
can hear on the tapes with Johnson and
Nixon this is the operative pole this is
the operative policy making decision how
will it look and and so we ended up
getting a lot of Americans killed
because of the as one of our Marines
says in the film the ego of some of
these people talk about Neil Sheehan
he's one of the reporters that you
mentioned and he he's a major voice in
the
comentary and he says he went there and
I I mean I guess it's a holdover from
World War two in Korea where the press
corps were very pliant and compliant
with a national security narrative they
show up in Vietnam and they're buying
into it and then they have an awakening
well you know I think it raises the
question of what is patriotism I think
they felt and he says it's very
beautifully in the film that you know as
a patriotic American you wanted to help
us win the war and to win the war was to
tell the truth about the war so we could
we could do it better
that was his initial impulse over time
he became disillusioned as many many
people didn't spend a lot of time in
Vietnam seeing that it really wasn't
working the way we thought and he had
some very enlightened field commanders
explained to him why the way we were
waging the war was actually
counterproductive so you know if you get
sniper fire from a village you send
artillery you literate a village well
that makes a lot more enemies than the
one sniper you were trying to get and
you multiply that exponentially over
many villages over many years you have
had hard time winning the hearts and
minds of the people and that's not how
the narrative of the body counts really
adds up so he you know over he really
believed in the cause and wanted to help
and over time wanted to then expose what
was going wrong in the war there's a
moment and I think it's episode 5 where
somebody is talking with a news reporter
is talking with a bunch of soldiers and
they're kind of like you know this is
all kind of you know [ __ ] up it's
weird you know like things are not going
well that kind of access to troops in
the field well is stunning this is how
is this is the gun this is a key
ingredient well you know world war war
World War two it was really constricted
and limited and Korea as well
Vietnam everybody you just sort of
checked in you got your credentials and
promise not to betray ongoing operations
and then you're free and what happened
is is that the Vietnam War revealed
itself to the press and they reported it
back to the United States this is what
the war in Vietnam is all about
the Marines of burn this old couples
cottage because fire was coming from
here this is a huge and very important
factor and a lot of very brave
journalists lost their lives and a lot
of very brave journalists gave us time
to tell us you know what happened and
it's a significant factor in all of this
and what the military learned thereafter
is that we're not doing that anymore so
the embed idea is a way of babysitting
a journalist under the guise of saying
hey you can begin on the act yeah you
can be in on the action but what it
means is that you know you're not gonna
ever get to the point where you're gonna
watch as Morley Safer did soldiers
burning a village in kind of retaliation
for the fact that they received some
fire from that and then quite frankly
just saying as as teenage warriors often
do you know we have no feeling for these
people even though the obvious calculus
that lid is saying that if you destroy
the village you're creating more enemy
seems so self-evident we even have a
tape back from a young army guy who
comes from South Central Missouri and
the Ozark Mountains and he takes a
reel-to-reel tape recorder he makes
tapes for his family his family which
owns the general store gathers all the
neighborhoods and they give reports back
it's really a just beautiful real-life
American but at some point he says you
know the army does everything backwards
here because they're having us burn down
these villages but that's gonna just
make more enemies so here you got you
know what we would say was a dumb hick
who's very much as equal to the
so-called best and the brightest who are
plowing us deeper and deeper into this
disaster if you can talk briefly about
the documentary method I mean there is
so much footage so much still
photography so many data I mean Ju if
you just wanted to do a report on the
the Pentagon Papers that could that
could be a thousand hours how did you
cuz their kool-aid through the throat
area
I mean first we should say that it's our
colleagues that do most of that sifting
and combing we have incredible team of
producers and then our editors and our
writer Jeff Ward all you know put in
hours and hours and hours of work trying
to find the perfect quote the perfect
photograph the perfect piece of footage
for the huge story that we're trying to
tell and then getting the rights and the
archives all around the world and
getting access to the Vietnamese
archives so we could actually represent
their story the way they saw it at the
time it's an epic undertaking and you
know what you see on the screen has a
lot to do with the genius of the people
who know you could do an entire episode
on the Pentagon Papers and it's fine
and but that's not what we've sort of
tried to put together in a kind of an
epic novel in which you have many
primary secondary tertiary characters
and do it as a saga over many many
generations that we believe this story
is and so necessarily you're constantly
making decisions you know there was one
point in the script where the the Kent
State killings is one line well it's now
a significant scene in our film of ten
or fifteen minutes which is forever in a
film of this size even though we're
looking at ten 90-minute emphasize
another ten there are some er two hours
six or two hours and and four or nine
minutes a lot of time it's not your time
but so yeah but even a minute is a lot
of time and and then there are things
that are perhaps worthy of a full to our
treatment in a documentary that we've
reduced down back to that sentence
because there's a kind of respiration to
storytelling everybody knows this
journalists know this too that the thing
you think is going to be expanded is
actually contracted and this moment that
you thought was just going to be that
deserves some other thing and so we're
mindful of it and and having to spend
ten years on it which we demanded of
ourselves made it possible for us to
make those kinds of decisions and we
know now as we've experienced in other
films ruminate on the civil war on
baseball on jazz on the national parks
that other filmmakers are going to go in
and take that 15 minutes the subject
that we covered perhaps in 15 minutes
and turn it into a wonderful film on
their own but our job is to try to
stitch together the complicated
narrative so that you at least can
apprehend or maybe appreciate a part of
the whole in a lot of ways the most
painful and revelatory episode was the
final one which is basically I mean each
up
so it has a kind of timeline on it and
this one I think it says 1973 and
onwards so it details in a way that I
had not seen before I know I'm 53 I was
born in 63 I'm at the end of the baby
boom so Vietnam is kind of like a vague
memory but then I lived through the you
know the growth of the Vietnam movie and
the late seventies and things like that
but you detail the fall of South Vietnam
in the mid seventies and part of the
part of what you're doing there is a
kind of underscoring that America had
already tuned out yes why had America
lost interest because if you're fighting
a proxy war it means that rather than
have nuclear Armageddon with the Soviet
Union or Red China you've decided that
you're going to do this and we're not we
haven't really learned how to do limited
Wars as art has our current policies
have shown as well and so when you begin
as policymakers realizing that there's
much bigger fish to fry I mean we
there's an unbelievable tape from Nixon
and saying you know we're playing a
Russia game we're playing a China game
we're playing a re-election game you
know I mean these are much more
important than Vietnam
[Music]
so it's easy to suddenly renege on your
promises or or just say see you later
and to the president of Vietnam
understood that he says you know it's
like a Nixon when he found China has
found a new mistress we're old and tired
you know and that's not far from the
truth and and this is part of the
sobering reality of trying to order what
actually happen and not just be
susceptible to the conventional wisdom
that has kept us for 42 years since the
fall of Saigon arguing at each other and
over each other what you know speaking
of the that you know there was a spate
of movies certainly by the mid seventies
you know and things like coming home the
The Deer Hunter Apocalypse Now that were
all Oscar bait were widely discussed
what did they and novels Tim O'Brien the
brilliant writer of the things I carried
and going after Koch Giotto is in it's
in the documentary and just thinking
about him reciting some of his words it
gives me chills it's really fantastic
but what did they fail to kind of
excavate to kind of exorcise the ghost
of it well I think that what they were
as they were fictions which meant they
could take liberties with the truth and
and that's what fiction is there to do I
mean my goodness the greatest switcher
of timelines and even countries and the
conflation of characters a guy named
William Shakespeare who we think does a
pretty good job at that and we're not
going to prescribe the people even now
the Oliver Stone's who wish to give us a
very we work in public broadcasting
which is the only place where something
like this this enterprise could have
taken place the marketplace does not
support an enterprise like this creates
public TV no it did not no no not at all
it was an act of Congress in Johnson and
we have one foot in that marketplace but
the other tentatively out but nobody
would have been able to devote the
millions of dollars in the 10 years
there's no business model that would
have had that happen to permit us almost
like a scholarly study you know where
we've gone off and worked with scholars
over that time to to be able to tell
that story so I think it's less the
failure we don't miss wish to make the
other movies wrong they had their own
fish to fry and axe to grind and and
perhaps political axe to grind but we
didn't we had a much larger charge that
we made to ourselves that required the
10 years which no Hollywood studio would
permit and the kind of resources that we
were able to bring to bear money that we
raise from public and private sources
and our corporate underwriter you know
that's all how we were able to do it so
we would just like to say we'd like to
add this we've heard back from some of
those directors saying wow this is
fantastic and I wept all the time yes I
mean I would just add to that that you
know I don't think we have to
distinguish between fact and fiction in
terms of trying to understand this
enormous the complicated story right
because there's no one right way to see
it and in our research and trying to put
our arms around the subject we did find
useful to read The Things They Carried
as well as Tim O'Brien's memoir and to
read a novel by a North Vietnamese
soldier about neem called the Storrow of
war which was the first novel in
published in Vietnam to give voice to
the spirits of ordinary soldiers and
it's a devastating book it's been
likened to ah quite on the Western Front
and in terms of just wrestling but the
scale of loss and this sort of scope of
the tragedy for their country even
though they won the war and so you know
we all read that book multiple times
just try it because you can't find a
written history of the ordinary soldiers
of North Vietnam so if you want to
understand their experience you have to
actually read this book to be honest so
you know and I was just going to say the
other thing is there's a new novel that
came out a couple of years ago called
the sympathizer by a wonderful American
Vietnamese American writer at that time
when and he kind of brings together
Vietnamese perspectives on both sides
and you know he wakes the critique I
think very valid that in all those
American movies Hollywood movies about
the Vietnam War there's no Vietnamese
characters they don't say anything so
you don't hear from them so you're sort
of making the you know not a mistake but
you're overlooking as Ken said earlier
pretty important people who have an
important play the story yeah in a way
replicating the mistake that the the
generals not really know it the author
of the sympathizer says you know that
when Americans talk about Vietnam they
talk about themselves right and how can
you talk about the word Vietnam adding
war to it and not feel obligated to find
out that who these people were where
they're Vietcong guerillas are North
Vietnamese civilians or North Vietnamese
soldiers or the South Vietnamese who we
do a while allies who we do a really
good job of sort of dropping off at the
corner and say I'll be right back and
not showing up right in in one episode
it's actually the the marine Karl
Marlantes says and I'm quoting here
think about how many times we get
ourselves into scrapes as a nation
because we're always the good guys
sometimes I think if we thought that we
weren't always the good guys we might
actually get in less Wars has America
changed its self-image when it comes to
military interventions you know we
learned some lessons and the military
was very anxious to learn the lessons
and applied it certainly with Desert
Storm to have a very clear rationale a
very clear sense of beginning and middle
and end and just sort of that you're
talking about the 1990 yes the early in
January of 91 and then no subsequent
very brief land war and then the halt of
that that was all a magnificent sort of
demonstration of the military trying to
apply all the lessons and that in the
sense of getting a wide like a true
consensus yes exactly
so a very specific ideal that we were
going to get Saddam Hussein out of
Kuwait and we had a very a very sort of
clear enemy who had done a bad thing
invaded in other countries so that you
know it it hearkened back to other very
clear delineated were world wars that we
fought but the military I think still
continues to wish to understand this but
it's the policymakers who actually
succumb for domestic political
considerations Reid will I get reelected
but also the kind of sentimentality and
the very deep and darkest secret is that
as Karl Marlantes says in our film we
are not the DOM
species on the planet because we're nice
and people say that the military turns
young men into killers I would suggest
it's only finishing school so somewhere
in our human nature we are susceptible
and our memories are very short with
regard to the cost of war we become
susceptible to war as a legitimate
policy not just alternative but a first
choice and we're I mean I remember when
my civil war series came out in the fall
of 1990 the month before Saddam Hussein
had gone into Iraq and American public
85% were excited about going to war yes
we should go to war we hadn't had one in
a long time and we can win this baby
right and after the civil war series was
aired that dropped by like twenty five
percent a pollsters said and and we
considered that the best review we've
ever had which is all this was was a
reminder of what wars cost is and and
that the human memory you know or the
other thing that we do is in crust it
with sentimentality and nostalgia we
call the second world war the good war
it's the worst war ever 60 million
people it's the greatest Cataclysm in
human history and somehow it's morphed
into the good one we understand why
right because we were unambiguous about
why we went in there wasn't half the
population that was four and a half the
population against and you thought the
country was coming apart and we sort of
yearned for that clarity well you're not
gonna get it if you romanticize war and
its cost while I was watching the series
there was a deep very disturbing
generational irony at work so Vietnam
was prosecuted largely or was
orchestrated by the greatest generation
the people of one world war ii and korea
are thought to a draw there and they
inflicted it on the baby boom generation
who hated you know at the time I mean
they hated their parents generation of
for many things including the Vietnam
War but now the wars were in are being
prosecuted and they were orchestrated by
the baby boom generation on Millennials
essentially what did baby boomers fail
to learn from Vietnam well it's it's
what I just said it's the human sort of
inclination toward war but I would say
that it
it that the baby-boomers didn't hate the
previous generation they were adapting
new musical tastes and they were
adapting new sexual tastes and they're
adapting new dynamics about race and
about other things and encounter
cultural stuff but many of the people
that we interviewed particularly in the
early part of the year we're trying to
actually be like their parents and ran
into a brick wall of this isn't the
clear-cut thing that my dad did by
fighting in the Pacific or fighting in
France and there was a huge disconnect
there it's later on as the anti-war
movement grows and that army grows
completely disillusioned and I think
what happens is that each generation is
the same human nature never changes and
so it's going to inevitably war will be
seem attractive memories will be short
and will say let's go and do that I mean
you can hear saber rattling at almost
any time in our culture can I just
interrupt you briefly to say oh that
it's interesting said there were
basically five presidents three
Republicans two Democrats involved in
Vietnam there if you include Bill
Clinton with Iraq because he pushed for
regime change as an official position in
the nineties we've got four or five
presidents all of whom are baby boomers
some got some Republicans involved in
these limited wars that are longer than
the Clinton and Bush they both got
deferments romp was not we've been
wrestling with you know what what is
going on how does it relate to what
happened in Vietnam and I think we're
not making the same mistakes where we
seem to be making other mistakes that
are related and one of them though
that's a theme I think is that we
Americans even though we've learned many
lessons about how to fight a limited war
better or in counterinsurgency and
limits of power and you know having to
make friends and not just worry about
body count I mean there's certain things
in the press access all of that those
are lessons that we have absorbed in the
military and the politics is absorbed
the thing that we can't let go of and
maybe we shouldn't but this is a
question is that we still seem to think
that people far away in other countries
want what we have to offer and that we
can bring them democracy
in the kind of society open society that
we have and that if we just offer them
the kind of from the menu of options
that we have in Afghanistan or in Iraq
that they're going to embrace what who
we are and what we're bringing and that
you know the idea that you can go to a
country far away and insert yourself
into something and somehow understand it
well enough and make things happen I
mean this argument about nation building
or region sculpting okay yes much easier
said than done indeed yeah it's a big
tension but you know what our role is
and you see the pendulum swinging back
that we should look inward it's
isolationist now it's populist it's
nationalistic it has all the dangers
inherent in that but the other swing of
the pendulum is a kind of robust
military presence in every place the
world's policeman I remember once during
the Vietnam era my father read an
article to me and it said that if the
United States gave every South
Vietnamese six hundred thousand dollars
which is staking them to an incredible
capitalist opportunity we would have
bought out the entire country and not
spent what we had spent in the war and
maybe we should just go I mean if you
think about our early success in
Afghanistan the CIA alone goes in there
with bags of money and buys the end of
the Taliban and the regime there and
that's an amazing thing and then somehow
we lose sight and they're not enough big
contractors who are getting the money
and so and and the idea that that
Eisenhower warned us about quite
correctly of the military-industrial
complex which he did at the end of his
second term he wasn't saying this is
something that I just noticed grew up
last Thursday
this happened in 1945 when those
enormous profits that were made in
prosecuting the Second World War they
didn't want the profits to end and so a
good deal of this is the market sort of
influences and forces well it you know I
would argue it's more politics but it's
it's stunning that yeah that Eisenhower
in 1960 is talking about you know the
problems with the standing army the guy
who won World War two exactly and when
was that listen twelve well you could
make an argument and I'm sure that there
will be some person much smarter than me
that will bring up the example but we've
won all the wars we weren't prepared to
fight yeah right and all the wars we
were prepared to fight we have not won
you know and so we had an army in 1940
the size of Romania's and people were
running around with leggings from the
first world war and tin hats and we had
more cavalry horses than we had tanks
and you know five years later we were
the dominant army on earth of my father
and uncles were in that and they were
not prepared for war nah couple weeks
later so I don't know I mean politics is
a huge force but I think we have all of
these things and you know TR was a
complicated and very flawed leader
understood that government could it
sometimes be a countervailing force
between what Marx would say was the
dialectic between labor and and and
capital and and so I I do think that if
you're making billions of dollars in
profits you're on an effort and somebody
says the war is over and you make tanks
you want to sell more tanks correct me
if I'm wrong politics in the end if you
talk about crony capitalism and the
influence of money not just now but then
on that so I would say the
interrelationship of all of these forces
is so impossible to separate in a kind
of ideologically pure way that we have
to sort of see human endeavor as a big
mess and try to superimpose some
narrative structure on it that makes
some sense and is honest and right now
that's not a given because we live in a
world of fake news and and and
deliberate disinformation that's being
planted and seeded by within our own
society and by other societies and that
that makes our job much more complicated
one of the things that is fascinating
and I think it's true both about the
your documentary and and the
moment where this is not contained by
obvious ideology of Democrat Republican
liberal or conservative Vietnam started
as a kind of liberal Hawk project in
many ways and then it you know it became
you know a conservative project as well
just as the wars in Afghanistan or the
Middle East are and yeah that's worth
thinking about well you know that thing
we spoke was about prohibition and the
only reason why prohibition happened is
because all of a sudden the progressive
we might say left-right suddenly had
common cause with the Conservatives who
were trying to keep the booze away from
the immigrants and from the blacks that
had been newly freed and and the
progressives thought you could through
social engineering fix things and all of
a sudden you have a majority that can
pass the legislation and the amendment
necessary to happen so I think in in
some of the as Karl Marlantes also says
we quoted him a lot today the [ __ ]
sandwich of Vietnam you know a lot of
that is coming from the fact that you
had all of these best and brightest
whose ideological ideologically I think
the lines are pretty blurred you know
and and and it just maybe in the end
that it's maybe money behind it maybe
the end it's it's something else but we
ended up with what happened talk about
the soundtrack the you know a and I hate
to I mean it sounds almost trivial but
the soundtrack because Vietnam was as
you've called it it's a decade of acting
but also the soundtrack is pretty rich
from the beginning of the of the early
60s
let me just say one thing music is the
fastest art there is two notes and you
can actually begin to feel something so
with that in mind it is not trivialize
it is a central part of it and too often
people add a soundtrack at the end to
sort of add the icing you know for you
know hope that it's it you know that
it's pumping up emotions you hope you
hope are there we do it differently you
know we had the great privilege
extraordinary opportunity to work with
Trent Reznor and Atticus Ross can and I
really could not believe our luck to
this day we will never get over it
they're just great great artists they
are able to distill complex emotions
many of them
contradictory at the same time and
graced us with an extraordinary original
compositions that are willing throughout
the film and really sort of embody the
complexities and contradictions of this
incredible tragedy that we're trying to
tell then we also had the privilege to
work with yo-yo ma and the Silk Road
Ensemble and these are the greatest
musicians from around the world on some
very interesting instruments to give
voice to Vietnamese music but also sort
of universal human feelings we had
through the incredible work of our
producer sarah Botstein the privilege of
working with the greatest recordings of
this era and this is as Ken said some of
the greatest music that America has ever
created and England as well and so you
know everyone you've heard of Bob Dylan
the Rolling Stones The Beatles Jimi
Hendrix Janis Joplin makes it appear
yeah right Sarah Botstein was able to
talk to the artists their States their
publishers their representatives and
sort of explain to them what we were
trying to do and they all want it in
they want to be part of this story
because they wanted their music to be
understood by a new generation in
particular that didn't know it in
context they've heard it on the radio
you know my kids love this music too
it's it's sort of iconic timeless music
but it actually did happen in a time in
place so we're putting it in the time
and place and which had happened and
also showing that it was listened to by
the soldiers in the field and also the
people back home there wasn't sort of us
and them in terms of music music was the
glue that really sort of kept the
country together as insofar as it was
together and so I mean you know it's
like kid in the candy store I mean
there's just not even a metaphor we can
use to say what are your favorite songs
of the greatest music that you can
imagine and ok we can use it let's put
it in the film and then it can be shown
you know it creates an authenticity for
the people who live through it when they
see the film that they remember those
moments and the music makes sense of
them because that's what they heard then
and if you didn't live through it then
you now understand what they are saying
when they're singing some of these songs
there's a moment in the final episode
where so it's maybe like 7475 Kashmir by
Led Zeppelin comes out ok this is worth
waiting for
yeah no no I agree completely when our
editor
put it and I told him I said that was
brilliant because it's a lesser-known
it's not an obvious thing but it speaks
instantaneously to the momentum to the
emotion just like the Reznor music and
the yo-yo mom music does as well but
it's so it's so great in fact we're
trying to figure out the playlist of it
and I I've been arguing for getting
Kashmir
instead of dazed and confused right you
seem to give us more obvious choice for
a great rock and roll bro well we will
leave it there we have been talking with
Lynn Novick and Ken Burns their latest
series debuting on September 17th on PBS
is Vietnam thanks so much for talking
with you thank you thank you for having
us this great conversation yeah really
really wonderful
[Music]
you
[Music]